i've thought the exact same thing
about the way in which trump was
referred to as hitler
and then there was no reckoning with the
fact that that wasn't true
i actually think that's a that's an
incredibly serious matter
we had the exact same thing in the uk
there were protests against trump
i went to them to observe them every
other placard had trump with a hitler
moustache
telling us that the 1930s were coming
back
and none of them have um apologized for
doing that
or reassessed the situation
or admitted that they were being
hysterical they've just let it slide
into
history and i think that's unforgivable
firstly because it describes trump in an
inaccurate way he's not hitler
the people who voted for him are not
right-wing fascists
um so they were lying about trump and
they were lying about trump's support
base
but also it is part of this process of
holocaust
relativism which i think is a really
worrying phenomenon
because the more that you compare all
relatively ordinary political events
in the present the more that you compare
those things to what happened in the
1930s the more you
make the 1930s seem ordinary
and mundane and it chips away at the
uniqueness
of the holocaust and it chips away at
the seriousness of that moment and the
fact that this was the greatest
crime in human history and
contributes to the broader um
belief that the holocaust was not
particularly a big deal
the nazis were bad people in the same
way that trump is a bad person
um and that again is another example of
just historical
ignorance and historical illiteracy and
and the
terrible consequences that can have for
people's understanding of the past and
for their understanding of what
certain groups of people experienced in
the 20th century
i think your idea of
creating the possibility of another
candidate someone who's not
trump and who's not not trump
which is what biden and harris are i
think that's really interesting and
my view of political life at the moment
is anything that can be done
to open the door to a new possibility is
worth pursuing
this is why i'm quite interested in the
rise of populist parties
in europe now some of these populist
parties are bad they have
awful beliefs some are good some are far
right some are far left
um you know there are all sorts of
parties but what i think is fascinating
and important and quite
encouraging about them is that they are
trying to create
another possibility something that isn't
the conservative right-wing section of
society and something which isn't the
kind of
collapsing social democratic wing of
society and they're trying to open the
door to something else
all forms of political experimentation
if they are driven by a desire to
democratize public life and to re
to reintroduce reason and
freedom and equality to the heart of
public debate
anything that does that i think should
be welcomed and encouraged
yeah i i agree it must be and
the basis for it being incredibly
vibrant is
there but it is going to be shouted out
of existence before it gets a chance
to uh to actually flourish
now i i agree with your analysis about
the 1930s and the the real hidden danger
here is that
we have robbed the very special and
important claim that something is
hitlerian
of all meaning so that as it returns we
can no longer invoke it and have it
resonate and i i must say i feel this
you know both as you know an
analytically
focused person who recognizes that that
must be the case but also as a jew who
knows
that you know i'm beginning to hear a
kind of um
commonplace anti-semitism in this
woke ideology that uh is so familiar
from what i read about and heard about
as a young person
that um i know the danger isn't
where we were told it is and it is
exactly in
the hands of those who are shouting nazi
this nazi that